karis bishop is one of the leading
voices and journalists in the us when it
comes to big tech and its connection
with power and politics she has covered
silicon valley and the major players
that have made the industry as powerful
as it is today
with big tech becoming a major influence
in today's polit political world it's
important to understand where we are and
where
the industry is going now let's hear
from cara herself thank you cara
and welcome social media
obviously played a big role in the
preparation of storming
the capital do you agree january 6
is kind of the 911 for social media
well i don't know i think it's a 9 11
for a lot you know it's not i don't want
to compare those crisis
you know because that was the amount of
the amount of deaths that that thing was
really quite amazing but it was it is a
moment to reflect on
the impact of not just social media but
media in general on
on on getting people um amplified and
weaponized and i think that's really
what it was and a lot of you know look
donald trump being down
at the down at the white house yelling
at them to do that was just as important
as what had prepared them to feel that
way and act once he said
you know gave the go word essentially
and so what these people have been doing
is they've been inhaling and
been flooded with all kinds of
misinformation lies
a lot by donald trump but a lot
everywhere and so they've been
surrounded by lies and therefore when he
said go fix it
it was he had softened them up he and
others had softened them up to do what
they did and
i don't think people i do people people
have free will but when you get into a
mindset
and you believe it because you're
surrounded by media that's telling you
that what's happening is being taken
to it it's not as confusing to
understand why they did what they did
you know they look like idiots but are
they or are they people that were just
incredibly manipulated and that's
something obviously germans know about
really well
and so this idea of constant re uh
reaffirmation
of things that are untrue created this
situation that led to that for sure
cara is the tech industry at all
complicit in allowing the storming to
occur what's your
what's your take on that yeah i think
one thing that you have to separate is
two things they may have done the right
thing by by de-platforming donald trump
in this moment
but everything that's led up to it has
been because they haven't done anything
and they have allowed
everything to go on including all this
misinformation including the behavior of
donald trump
and and his minions you know what i mean
it's it's an entire network
where misinformation bubbles up and
bubbles back down and so
yes the way they built their platforms
has caused this situation to happen
giving them kudos for finally doing the
right thing i'm not sure you get a kudos
for
doing the right thing which is in this
case it's the correct uh
answer but it also points the fact that
how much power these companies have and
way too much power
that sometimes they make the right
decision but boy do we not like that it
took
two companies to shut this down just two
people and that's problematic in this
country
do they have to rethink their whole
model i mean now is they're kind of also
taking over by all these
conspiracy theories and you know would
you say that and
and yes oh how well you know they they
everyone's sort of like how could this
happen
everything was built this way the way it
is built is the way it is behaving
because it reflects humanity
and anytime humanity gets any kind of
tool like this they the abuse of it is
usually
right away and so i think one of the
things that's built around advertising
it's built around engagement
it's not built around community even
though they say it is
and so it therefore what what has
happened is what should happen
because this is this is the kind of
tools they build and so the question is
is there engagement oriented business
plan
a good business plan in this eight in
this highly politicized age and also
it if engagement along with addiction
of these platforms and things like that
um lead to this
enragement is not really a business we
need to be in and it leads to enragement
inevitably and not to the the better
outcomes that they say they could lead
to it doesn't it there's so much proof
of where this goes
but it is their business their business
model so
what how could they change that well you
can imagine like
like think about in the business you
know tv has a business model of
advertising and you could
you know you saw the movie network you
know you could make it into
if it was the only thing people were
getting and they were getting them
individual messages aligned to them
you could see how that could be abused
well we have a we have uh
government entities that control the
airwaves in some way and there there are
um there's there's there's lawsuits that
happen when you
break a rule and in this case the
internet industry doesn't have any
laws god burning them and therefore they
can do whatever they want
every other major media as much as we go
on about freedom of speech here every
media has some strictures on it and we
have to figure out what the structures
are for this media
and it's going to have to come from
government not from them because they
can't self-self-regulate
so uh cara we often talk about we need
more
regulation on these big big overpowerful
companies
that were actually allowed to become so
big in the past
maybe we can focus or talk a little bit
about the mistakes which are happening
now you know maybe you can give us a
couple of examples
of where governments need to be taking
action right now that we don't kind of
run into the same situation well the
european union has
you know margaret vestiger and others
have tried on lots of different things
not just not just around
speech but actually around power and
that's what this is about like let's
just be honest it's like not about
speech every all the right wing goes on
and on about speech and they never shut
up that's a fascinating kind of
development is that they talk about
being censored and you can't stop
listening you can't they never stop
broadcasting
so i think it's an issue of that there's
not been any regulation and the
regulation should be around market
concentration market power
because with innovation and the ability
to have more companies you have more
voices it solves the problem
if you don't have two companies in
charge one company in charge of social
media one company in charge of search
one company in charge of
commerce you're going to inevitably lead
to abuses and then the lack of
innovation means the lack of voices
and so we need regulation you know
around privacy we need regulation around
liability for some of these companies et
cetera et cetera and so there's
there aren't any rules that's like in 20
years there's there's one rule that
helps them
and so i don't mean to say we should get
rid of section 230 which is the
is the one that's always controversial
but we need to reform it because
it was it was done at a time when these
were in our international search
interrupt
explain our international audience what
that is 1930 section 230 is a law that
was part of another act that largely was
declared unconstitutional but not this
part of it which
gives broad immunity to internet
platforms for third-party
material on their you know so they're
not liable for everything everybody says
on facebook that would just be put it
out of business instantly
facebook was not in existence when this
happened by the way it was way before
any of these companies
and so it was because if that these
companies were not really media but they
weren't
really platforms and so how do you how
do you protect them from being sued out
of business
well now they've used that to grow to
great proportions and not have
enough responsibility around what's on
their platforms and so it suggests you
don't have responsibility and so now we
have to sort of move the responsibility
back to these
very wealthy companies because each of
these companies is now the biggest
companies in the world now
they're not nascent they're powerful
they are the most powerful the richest
their owners are the richest people in
the world
and therefore the rule has to be
rewritten for the reality of the
situation today
but they are so powerful do you think
this will really happen
well john d rockefeller was powerful
somehow they got him in
you know what i mean they rain everybody
and government is the only solution in
this case because
you know consumer pressure is important
media pressure is important
um grassroots activist efforts is
important
but the only thing that's going to rain
these people is the government and you
know what we got rid of att
we hit microsoft we got john d
rockefeller big oil
it's the trains this is something that's
you know
teddy roosevelt was a trust buster and
therefore there is a way
to to do this and there's a history in
this government of this company country
of doing that so
did people say they're too powerful well
you know so are a lot of people
you just mentioned uh margaret westorger
the
eu commissioner she's probably the most
powerful
woman in the world when it comes to
regulation if you would be in her shoes
for one day
which executive order now what what what
what would you do like if you're doing
all the things i think sometimes she
goes a little far but that's okay
um you know i think europe has a very
different idea about privacy than the us
does i think first amendment issues you
you can't do a lot of things in the u.s
that she's allowed to do right
the first amendment does get in the way
with government you know it's very clear
government shall make you know congress
shall make no law
governing freedom of speech so among
other things and so
you have to work within those boundaries
here um but
in her case she has power in europe and
the areas she's regulating she doesn't
have power in the u.s
and these companies are largely u.s
based companies and so it has to be the
us government
uh not the state governments california
has been trying to do pro has done a
privacy bill
california is the one leading a lot of
this legislation around all the internet
companies whether it's uber or anybody
else
so it has to come from our the us
federal government to govern
u.s companies and even though we're in a
global society and these are global
companies they're us companies and so it
has to come from here so i don't know
what else she can do except continue
when they move over into her area to
regulate them and then maybe set the
tone
like gdpr did for the rest of the world
what do you expect from the incoming
biden
administration regarding these topics
we're just talking about
i think it's gonna be bipartisan there's
a lot of people knowing that this is a
problem i
i i think there'll be more action
although you know it's interesting the
the
the i was waiting for lawsuits the
justice department anti-trust lawsuits
during the obama administration never
happened trump is trump
bill barr is the one who started the goo
who initiated the google the ftc
in this era is moving against facebook
now these these take a while to do
but i do see people like david cicilline
and some others on the hill being really
active in terms of figuring out what to
do here and
i i don't think the vitamins i think the
vitalization is is you know as much as
they get all called socialists
they're very centrist they're very
accommodating to the middle
and so i don't expect to see enormous
amounts i think the
the the the anti-trust lawsuits will go
on there'll be more
there'll be fines there'll be
regulations etc and that's
where you're going to see um i think
trump tried to do it in weird ways but
like
attack tick-tock but he didn't really
attack because he was so superficial
he just liked to type out executive
orders that were badly written
um and and had no had no force
no force of law and so i think it has to
be a bipartisan effort by a lot of
people
to real just the way all the other
regulations of big companies were and
then that's and and to remove the
politics out of it and talk about the
body politic of this country and and
how badly they're hurt by this power and
if we if we do it in terms of power and
not
partisanship everybody gets that there's
no not a republican or democrat that
doesn't understand
too much power in the hands of too few
people leads to abuses
no matter how nice those people are you
know and usually they're not so nice
some of them aren't so nice
um why was chancellor angela merkel
wrong about banning trump on twitter
um you know i think she
i was surprised by that i'm not sure it
was really odd because i was like you
know
he he lies almost incessantly he's using
a
a forum not a public form a private form
i i'm not sure that was super
you know look twitter and facebook are
private companies they can do whatever
they want
she for some reason i think she thinks
they're the public square
and they're not she they're private
money-making institution
companies and and i and they can do
whatever they please
i think what she was talking about was
that that um
newsworthy figures deserve to be heard
all the time but you know what i always
said about donald trump i'm like it's
not like he lived in a house
you know where downstairs there was a
podium that reached every media outlet
in the world this guy had plenty of
chances
to do that um and in this case he just
violated the rules of
a several different companies one too
many times
i don't think it's more complex than
that why did she say that what did you i
don't know you asked her i was i want to
ask her
i didn't even understand it i don't
think she was i think she thinks of the
public square
and that's what she was talking about
don't shut down the public school i'm
like sure don't
it's not shut down the public square is
not shut down donald trump is shut down
on twitter and facebook at a time of
crisis
because he was fomenting sedition you
know and inciting violence
very bright red line i wonder what she
said if he had said something about
pornography child pornographers and like
oh no let's leave that up too like
they they he violated rules of their
platform
multiple times and then he did it at the
very wrong time again
and they had had it they had given him
huge amounts of space to
make mistakes and he continued to abuse
that privilege
my car to challenge you a little bit in
that regard so on the one hand you say
they are far too powerful
and then you say but they still should
have the power to regulate
and ban people i'm talking about yeah so
it shouldn't
that i think there should be more of
them there should be more of them so
people have
options right that's what i'm talking
about you have to separate out the two
there's
there's if they made the right decision
the moment based on the fact their
private companies this guy violated at
the time they don't want to have
terrorism on their
hands right they don't want to have
facilitated terrorism and that's what
this was
and so they can make that business
decision in the moment i don't i think
they have that but
the fact that it was two people that
stopped it and that's the only two
people we could go to
is the problem and so you have to
separate in the in the
in the anger of the moment you have to
separate out what the problem is the
problem ultimately is power
too much power in the hands of too few
that said they did the right thing you
know what i mean it's hard to like
i don't know it's that but they're the
only people we could go to
if there were dozens of places it
wouldn't have had the impact but it was
one place right and so that's the
problem is one
or two people mark zuckerberg and jack
dorsey had the in this case it was
someone else at twitter
had the power to shut something down
that's scary to anybody
who thinks about power thank you last
kind of
a question um i mean you you are a
journalist yourself
and to know that you've experienced that
yourself i'm sure
this country here is like people are
living really in two worlds i mean i've
never seen
this country being not only so divided
but i mean when i talk to
to people they they have totally
different information and takes
yeah what does all that mean for
democracies
i think you think we were together
before we weren't i don't think we were
i i think that's people talk about that
a lot i'm like it's just
what's happened is a lot of people have
bad information diets right and that's
we used to have three networks and that
was what everybody
consumed right by the way those three
networks were run by
16 men on the upper east side of new
york all of whom were white and rich so
i'm not so sure
that was great right um in this case
it's bad information diets is what's
happening
just like our obesity crisis people are
eating bad food they're fat and they're
dying of
hypertension or whatever their diabetes
or this and that
so i i do think you think we were more
together than you were
than we were i don't think we were at
all i think we just weren't hearing from
those people i think they were down
somewhere else where they weren't able
to communicate with each other and now
they
share information a lot of which is
dangerous and bad
and that's the problem i think really
but i think this idea that the us was
always
one big happy country not a country i
lived in
for a long time you know uh and so i
think it's just you can see it now
you can see it because it's all people
instagram the revolution not the red we
were called a revolution the
insurrection
the the coup the people of broadcasting
the coup but they thought that before
and they did have distrust for
government and donald trump just
scratched an itch that was already there
but i was down there at the mall on
january 6
you know and so many people are just
convinced that the
the elections were stolen that they're
rigged and all that because of
and then i asked them so where do you
get your information from oh yeah from
the internet from my facebook groups
yeah
that's new right i mean uh yes yes they
just were do they were passing it yes
because now it looks like it's on a
screen and therefore it's more
uh believable right instead of just
hearing among your friends and this and
that yeah they've gotten they're
overwhelmed with misinformation and
disinformation both
and that's the and malevolent players
trying to manipulate them but again
people propaganda hasn't changed in
hundreds of years this is propaganda
on steroids is what it is and that's
what you're seeing
and and again look you know mussolini
didn't need the internet to do what he
did hitler didn't need the internet to
do what he did
but this imagine if they had that
imagine if any autocratic leader
back in the day had that ability not
just to use
force physical force but to use mental
force in a way that is
turbocharged boy that would have
that would have been something terrible
yeah by talking about the future of this
country
i mean how how should god could
can joe biden or whoever is in charge
bring kind of
people together at least on a common
ground where they talk about
facts and yeah the reality if they just
live in
totally parallel worlds again i think
they've already been doing that because
you know there's a lot of people who
don't believe
the moon landing happened right or they
believe in sasquatch or
whatever this is just a more malevolent
strain it's like a virus right it's the
same but it's not different
i don't know i think there are some
commonalities that people do have
about uh i think this this
insurrectionist coup
um has made everybody go wait a minute
no
like maybe i should rethink and i think
there's certain people you're just never
going to reach
there's a 20 of our country who is just
uneducated
uh ill-informed and will not believe no
matter what you do there's just
we just if you don't think that was
there i know it was there i'm relatives
with some of them so
you know they were they were as dumb as
a box of hammers before this and they
now they have
like i have i get sent stuff and i'm
like this is from russia this is from
here
um and so i think when confirmation bias
is really important
um among these people and so if they're
all saying it together
they all believe it i there was a friend
of mine who had who had i'll give you
leave you this example who lived in a
small town in indiana moved to dc and
but there's a facebook group for this
town
and during the and the black lives
matters protests there was a whole
thread on this facebook group of the
town saying
you know antifa is coming here in buses
this town no one wants to go to this
town like
we're going to come here and they're
going to ruin downtown we need to board
up downtown this is going to happen
and she was on there she's like why
would anybody want to come to our shitty
little town right you know what i mean
they were convinced they were going to
do the same thing with the caravans or
whatever
and um and and it didn't happen of
course because
what the hell why would he they wanted
to think nobody literally taken this
indiana town was in nobody's interest to
do
and after it happened she's like look
see didn't happen
like and they were like well yeah
because we warned everybody like
they just can't you cannot if you're so
wrong you can't admit you're wrong
that's where the danger is like you
there's always somewhere there's going
to be a confirmation bias somewhere in
the in the ecosystem
and now you can click on a button and
get that confirmation bias
and that's the problem is you can always
find proof of your lunacy
um just recently now now so hugh anon
was wrong about donald trump winning
hunan was wrong about this you know they
keep being wrong
and that's they have to explain their
wrongness so they've got to come up with
a new plot
the new one which is crazy which i just
heard of is that
that if da if joe biden is put in place
i hate even repeating this but this is
what they're saying
if joe biden is inaugurated it's
actually trump because they switched
faces
that's their new thing they switch faces
like i'm like that was a movie with
nicholas gage and john travolta
it's called face off you friggin idiots
like that's where they go
they have to they can't be wrong and so
they come up with more and more
outlandish plots
and less and less people will believe
that as time goes on
as wrong and wrong and wrong they were
and i think the violence
you can see the polls people are like no
we're not this isn't us
and there is a there is a factor of that
in
in the in the american um
you know we have a virus we handled it
badly
we're going to get better at some point
and maybe reflect on what we did wrong
so
hopefully that'll work out we'll see who
knows
who knows cara will trump start his own
kind of media
outlet i think he's lazy and fat i don't
know what else to say
i mean that as a as a mental state also
a physical state but
i think he's lazy old and that and good
luck it's a lot of work to start a media
company you know what i mean like he can
talk about it he's one of those people
like every one of his executive orders
were had no force of law
nothing tick tock still going like the
230 is still going
there's no wall to speak of there's
mexico didn't pay for it
he can talk all he wants it's really
hard to start a media company and
uh bon seance i say good luck sir he
doesn't speak french but um
you know good luck good luck i i just
i'll believe it when i see it
how's that camera special thank you so
very much for your time and
talk to you soon all right thank you